[Musique]
pour être élu il faut une énergie folle
il faut une confiance folle il faut
foncer droit devant il faut partir à
fond et accélérer
tout président
au moment où accède à cette
responsabilité est enfermée
[Musique]
du calme il faut beaucoup de sang-froid
beaucoup doutés pour éviter de se
prendre un mur
mais il y a une très grande
contradiction dans la société française
nous voulons un président qui puisse
être au sommet
décider de notre destin commun et nous
le voulons accessible comment réussir
cette cette conjugaison c'est la
cinquième république mais qui est
Président fait partie de la famille des
gens qui vous aiment ou qui vous aiment
pas et donc il faut être prêt à payer le
prix
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas demandé à naître ses
enfants pourtant les voilà qui font leur
entrée en ce monde comment alors
naissance les promettre déjà à un avenir
digne de dans un monde prête à les
accueillir
[Musique]
de la pilule à la PMA les réformes de
société ont rythmées l'histoire de la 5e
République
chacun des 8 présidents a voulu ainsi
laisser sa trace une manière pour eux de
changer la vie des Français
françaises Français
sous de Gaulle un député Gauliste de la
première heure Lucien de virt convainc
le général pourtant très réticent
d'autoriser la pilule la contraception
empêche le train de partir alors que
l'avortement le fait dérailler
l'influence de Lucien nevt est tout à
fait considérable parce qu'il va casser
un certain nombre de choses dans la
famille gaullistes et le général était
sans doute très réticent au départ
Lucien de virtorat une alliée inattendue
[Musique]
Ivan de Gaulle la propre femme du
général
je me vois encore monter l'escalier il
ven escalier au milieu de la cour du
lycée et on se communiquait le fait que
il allait y avoir la pilule et c'était
enfin quelque chose qui bougeait dans
les tréfonds y compris pour des lycéens
boutonneux
et les nouvelles manifestation organisée
pour protester contre la fermeture de la
Sorbonne et les arrestations groupe 20
000 étudiants
1968 les ressorts du mouvement n'étaient
pas sur le social c'était vraiment sur
le sociétal des jeunes qui avaient
acheté dans cette société dans cette
société corseté dans laquelle les
garçons pouvaient pas fréquenter les
fils les filles pouvaient pas fréquenter
les garçons on était sur des
histoires d'un autre âge on voulait
passer à autre chose quoi le gaullisme
c'était une grande période c'était un
grand horizon c'était une grande
perspective mais il fallait un peu
ouvrir quelques fenêtres
[Musique]
de gros efforts ont été faits en matière
de contraception et les femmes
maintenant disposent de trois moyens
anti-conceptionnels le stérilet le
diaphragme et la pilule
[Musique]
je rentre ce qu'on appelle les
appartements
mais c'est quand même une façon de
couper avec le bureau je crois que c'est
mieux
quelques mois après son arrivée à
l'Elysée le président Pompidou doit
réagir un drame qui bouleverse la
société française
l'affaire Gabriel Russier les amours
d'un étudiant et de son professeur
scandalisent Aix-en-Provence la justice
s'en mêle et le cycle plein de procès
prison commence pour Gabriel Russie
Gabriel Russier qui a fini par se
suicider
monsieur le Président vous-même
qu'avez-vous pensé de ce fait divers qui
pose je crois des problèmes de fond je
vous dirai pas tout ce que j'ai pensé
sur cette affaire
ni même
ce que j'ai fait
ce qu'il a fait discrètement il a
demandé à l'éducation nationale de ne
pas sanctionner Gabriel Russier mais la
justice s'est montré implacable
quand est-ce que j'ai ressenti
comme beaucoup
comprenne qui voudra
moi mon remords ce fut la victime
raisonnable au regard d'enfant perdu
celle qui ressemble au morts qui sont
morts pour être aimés c'est de les Luard
cette histoire a été aussi pour la
société française quand même de dire
mais il faut sortir de tous ces
conformer la société était restée
compassée donc nous avions toujours ça
l'impression d'être dirigé par des vieux
messieurs surtout toutes ces troupes là
qui qui
suivait qui était quand même
tellement réactionnaire la vérité c'est
que toutes les femmes à voir y compris
les femmes de députés et les maîtresses
des ministres et tout le monde c'est moi
ne le dise pas pour la plupart des
femmes dans ce pays quand même il y
avait le sentiment que c'était pas tous
ces vieux grincheux là de décider à leur
place on avait besoin que la société
s'ouvre je vous garantis qu'il y aura un
changement
[Musique]
c'était quand même une autre image que
Monsieur Pompidou
jusqu'à
c'était ouvrez les fenêtres jusqu'à
était honnête complexe
c'était quelqu'un qui avait en lui une
pente absolument conservatrice par
moment
et dans d'autres moments une sensibilité
des antennes qui les mettaient au
contact de de ce qui avait de plus
progressiste on va dire notamment chez
les femmes il y a avec Giscard le
souhait de lire c'est la société civile
s'exprimer et là on sent qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est je pense un peu
nouveau dans la vie politique
[Musique]
le jour de son investiture pour imprimer
sa marque le président de la République
arrive à pied à l'idée
le nouveau président de la République
est jeune dynamique réformateur il veut
dépoussiérer la fonction présidentielle
c'était une chape de plomb qui se
soulevait ça a permis des réformes de
société qui sont venus après certaines
façons
l'IVG vient de là aussi peut-être
d'autres réformes sur sur les mœurs je
voudrais vous dire un mot maintenant de
notre effort de réforme
depuis que je vous parlais au dernier
coin du feu je m'aperçois d'ailleurs que
la dernière bûche était éteinte
le gouvernement entre prix trois
réformes d'une portée considérable vice
car était structurellement réformateur
donc on engageait pas un dialogue avec
lui sur le thème de la conservation
on savait que si on était conservateur
avec lui on n'a aucune chance d'être
écouté
[Applaudissements]
le président abaisse le droit de vote à
18 ans réforme le divorce et engage la
plus emblématique de ces réformes pour
les femmes la légalisation de
l'avortement
[Musique]
bon Giscard ça fait partie de la marque
de son temps la marque de son action la
marque de son époque et je crois que
Giscard veut surtout être dans l'air du
temps beaucoup de femmes avaient été
victime enfin avait non seulement
souffert mais certaines étaient mortes
quand même des avortements clandestins
Giscard et son premier ministre Jacques
Chirac font une place de choix à deux
femmes
issues de la société civile il nomme une
magistrate Simone Veil au ministère de
la Santé
[Musique]
Simone Veil mais déjà
une réputation il avait fait entrer
François Giroud aussi il crée un nouveau
secrétaire d'État à la condition
féminine qu'il confie à la célèbre
journaliste Françoise Jérôme
[Musique]
la condition de la femme alors
maintenant je crois que cette conscience
est très largement partagée justement à
cause de l'effort des ministres femmes
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes je
m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes j'en garde le souvenir d'une
d'abord d'une révélation quand même même
si cette femme nous était pas inconnue
de son courage cette attitude de Simone
Veil qui a été magnifique dans ce dans
ce débat elle était en résonance avec
le vécu de tellement de femmes celles
qui se trouve dans cette citation de
détresse qui s'en préoccupe c'était un
très bon choix de faire présenter ce
projet de loi par la ministre de la
Santé et pas par la ministre des femmes
c'est à dire que là c'était beaucoup
plus difficile pour l'opposition
réactionnaire qui faisait partie de la
majorité
quand même de s'opposer
pourtant le débat va être tendu violent
pendant 25 heures Simone Weil doit
répondre aux critiques farouches parfois
nauséabonde de nombreux députés de sa
propre majorité
des capitaux sont impatients de
s'investir dans l'industrie de la mort
et le temps n'est pas loin où nous
connaîtrons en France ces avortoirs ses
abattoirs les députés de droits ont été
soumis à une guerre d'influence
absolument considérable et l'influence
de l'Église catholique à ce moment-là
est tout à fait tout à fait importante
toxique et
nocivesment d'un cœur défaitus de 8
semaines et deux jours
[Musique]
Jacques Chirac qui était pourtant
réticent sur l'urgence de la réforme va
lui apporter un soutien précieux dans
les dernières heures
[Musique]
quelle est la sincérité de Jacques
Chirac sur cette question de l'IVG
à vrai dire je crois qu'il s'en
moquaient formellement et complètement
Jacques Chirac qui à l'époque était un
premier ministre ambitieux sur ce sujet
a réussi à être dans cette modernité qui
s'exprimer ces questions ne se n'est pas
la cam de Jacques Chirac pour parler un
peu vulgairement
et il a abordé cette affaire d'abord
sous un angle politique
avant de l'aborder sous le mode d'un
progrès social Simone Veil a fait
beaucoup parce qu'elle avait de bonnes
relations personnelles avec Jacques
Chirac c'est Jacques Chirac qui a fait
venir au gouvernement Simone Veil et
dans ses Mémoires Simone Veil dit
qu'elle a toujours eu la pluie sans
faille et elle dit sans phase et son mot
de Jacques Chirac
il suffit d'écouter les femmes
au petit matin après trois jours et demi
de débat la loi est adoptée grâce aux
voix de l'opposition de gauche ce débat
était difficile et c'est vrai que c'est
une loi voulue par la droite mais votée
par la gauche et je me souviens qu'on en
avait discuté à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste et on était unanime pour dire
qu'il fallait la voter tout ça était
pour notre génération quelque chose de
formidable et je pense que ça a beaucoup
aidé au succès de la gauche après Simone
Veil avec Giscard était quand même un
élément structurant notre vie politique
c'était une rupture entre la
bien-pensance et au fond disons
une dimension politique un peu plus
profonde plus historique les valeurs que
nous représentions la volonté d'ouvrir
le porte les fenêtres la volonté de voir
reconnu l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes tout ça
a formé un tout le monde société qui est
devenue au fil des années irrésistibles
j'étais très jeune au moment où il y a
eu le débat sur l'IVG mais j'ai vu la
courage de la part de la ministre mais
je pense aussi même s'il n'était pas de
ma sensibilité politique de la part du
Premier ministre de l'époque Jacques
Chirac et du président Giscard d'Estaing
de faire sans doute une réforme qui
était contraire à ce que penser
leur corps électoral il y avait beaucoup
de stérilité des catholiques qui avaient
une grande proximité avec jusqu'à mais
il avait fait ce choix et donc là il
veut des pâtes c'était d'une certaine
manière pas négociable il était sincère
il était en adéquation avec l'évolution
de l'époque voilà il a eu l'intelligence
de le comprendre et il a eu le courage
vis-à-vis de ses propres troupes de dire
voilà c'est comme ça je pense qu'il est
très important
si on veut être président de la
République d'être capable de reconnaître
que l'autre camp a parfois raison
mais en tout cas que le moment
historique est elle
qu'on peut s'affranchir
y compris de ces partisans parce qu'on
peut faire voter des lois qui sont
apparemment contraire à l'opinion
publique comme par exemple la peine de
mort
si on sent que c'est absolument
indispensable et qu'on peut convaincre
le pignon et c'est ça qui a été fait
aussi bien par Giscard d'un côté que par
François Mitterrand de l'autre
bonsoir
la France a peur la France a peur chaque
mer chaque père à la gorge nouée c'est
la peine de mort que l'avocat général de
la cour d'assises débouches du Rhône a
requis contre Christian Ranucci
soranucci et je vous le rappelle accusé
du meurtre de Marie Dolorès une fillette
de 8 ans l'affaire de Troie a évidemment
relancé le débat sur la peine de mort le
rapport de Mitterrand avec la peine de
mort
était
singulier
rarement mais parfois exécutés voilà la
réalité vous n'avez pas à me demander
mon raisonnement d'homme privé mais ils
n'ont pas raisonnable de mort jamais il
était intéressé par les grands procès
parce que c'est un avocat mesurant la
densité dramatique ça l'intéresse mais
sur le problème de la peine de mort ils
ne vont pas aller jamais il y avait pas
de réforme plus emblématiques que
celle-là
pour les valeurs de gauche pour
pour l'humanisme pour tout ce qui est
quand même
animé
Mitterrand et toutes celles et ceux qui
le suivaient il est devenu
abolitionniste quand il est devenu
Premier secrétaire est parti socialiste
parce que quand on est assis les rituels
Jaurès et le Bloom on ne peut pas ne pas
être abolitionniste
je crois pas cette idée mais il s'est
fait convaincre pour lequel il avait le
plus grand respect
et l'interpenait essentiellement à cet
article de loi
n'avait aucune estime pour les le sens
politique de balader aucune estime il
considérait que je n'étais pas
la bile politique
en revanche une très grande estime pour
ses convictions et pour l'homme qu'il
est à juste titre et
Valentin c'était son combat que à peine
de mort devait être abolition
c'était pour moi une évidence je
préférerais que ce soit un engagement au
prix devant le pays le moment c'est
jouer
en réalité
le sort de l'abolition
cette à la télévision
[Musique]
moi je lui avais téléphoné le matin je
connaissais bien le Cabasse je
connaissais bien Dieu humaine et je
savais que ça allait venir
[Musique]
votre obsession
en dehors de vous bon alors j'ai
simplement sur une page blanche
fait taper par ma secrétaire les grands
extraits des grands écrivains
et les adversaires de la peine de mort
et puis
j'ai été une Bièvre j'ai dit ça
secrétaire marie
ou le dossier il est là
j'ai une feuille avec je souhaite
ajouter et comme je le connaissais bien
je savais que allant au studio il
ouvrait
d'abord là-dessus il y a actuellement
cinq condamnés à mort dans des cellules
je voudrais savoir si vous étiez du
président de la République si vous
voulez grassiriez
pas plus sur cette question que sur les
autres je ne cacherai ma pensée et je
n'ai pas du tout l'intention de mener ce
combat à la face du pays
en faisant semblant d'être ce que je ne
suis pas
dans la conscience profonde qui rejoint
celle des églises même si la tournée ça
d'une façon
habile c'est-à-dire qu'il a fait
référence dans mon souvenir à ce que
pensent les églises etc qui allaient
dans le même sens que que l'abrogation
il a dit d'une manière nette oui je suis
pour l'abrogation je suis contre la
peine de mort
et je n'ai pas besoin de lire les
sondages
qui disent le contraire je me souviens
d'avoir vu à la télévision quand il a
dit l'opinion on lui a dit et l'opinion
est contre l'opinion est contre moi je
suis pour il a dit très clairement
je passe oublié ce qui était le climat
de l'époque
je rappelle que les deux tiers des
Français étaient très clairement sinon
violemment très clairement attaché au
matière de la peine de mort au moment où
la décision est prise
le peuple français
dans sa majorité il est hostile
devant tous les députés de droite avec
en première page
66% d'avis défavorable
à l'abolition
c'est ça la France de l'époque il y
avait de la part de Mitterrand
peut-être un défi il détestait pas ça
mais le fait de dire voilà je suis comme
je suis j'ai les convictions que j'ai et
à vous peuple français de décider si
vous m'acceptez tel que je suis je dis
ce que je pense ce à quoi j'adore ce à
quoi je crois ce à quoi se rattache mais
mes adhésions spirituelles ma croyance
mon souci de la civilisation je ne suis
pas favorable à la peine de mort comme
toujours chez lui
personnage si complexe
c'était à la fois
la conscience que il s'inscrivait dans
une histoire etc
et en même temps une forme supérieure
d'habilité politique à l'époque
Mitterrand était présenté comme
un politicien habile mais à sur
houblblard et finalement
auquel on pouvait pas faire grande
confiance pour ce qui est des
convictions mon semi-terron qui est le
garde des sourds qui a le plus condamné
à mort
ou soutenu des condamnations à mort
avait en lui je crois ça l'obsession
d'effacer
ce passé de son histoire tout le monde
le taxe de Machiavel
personage d'une comptabilité mais
peut-être parfois
compliqué et là sur un sujet aussi
important prendre j'allais dire à
rebrousse poil l'opinion en disant c'est
ma conviction et je l'appliquerai et
bien cette donnée une crédibilité
supplémentaire au reste de ses positions
cet acte de courage je ne sais pas si
c'est ça qui lui a fait gagner
l'élection mais cet acte de courage a
marqué l'opinion le courage politique
c'est le candidat qui dit moi pour des
raisons morales je choisis ce qui est un
populaire
aux yeux de la majorité je choisis parce
que la morale des termes d'abord mes
axes ma disposition est celle d'un homme
qui ne ferait pas procéder à des
exécutions capitales
[Musique]
j'étais très jeune
et je trouve que il a fallu un grand
courage au président Mitterrand je dis
Mitterrand
pas d'Inter
parce que celui qui a pris le risque
politique c'est le président Mitterrand
c'est pas monsieur Badinter monsieur
Bernadette un avocat
il défendait la thèse en quelque sorte
de son milieu professionnel
celui qui a pris le risque c'est
Mitterrand et le mérite revient
Mitterrand il savait qu'il était
minoritaire il l'a fait
ça ça m'impressionnait
[Musique]
tu es en gagne et il y avait énormément
de projets et de loi à faire voter
la question était à quel moment on
fait cette réforme
et je lui ai dit c'est très urgent
les résultats
voilà le nombre de condamnations à mort
intervenu depuis
vous avez été élu et je peux vous dire
ce qui va se passer il a dit à François
Mitterrand président maintenant vous
avez pris la décision tout le monde sait
que vous avez pris l'addition mais il
faut que la loi passe vite sinon on va
être dans ce paradoxe épouvantable vous
allez être dans ce paradoxe épouvantable
d'être
submergé presque submeries par les
condamnations à moi et donc Mitterrand
Macron contre le veut des Français en
Gratiant et par conséquent il faut
maintenir les choses en l'état
donc politiquement c'est très mauvais
Mitterrand il comprenait très très vite
ce genre de considération il m'a regardé
avec admis sourire et me dit pour une
fois Robert vous avez politiquement
récent
pour une fois ce débat est vieux de près
de deux siècles en ce moment le Garde
des Sceaux Robert Badinter répond au 30
orateurs qui se sont succédés à la
tribune il fait appel une nouvelle fois
leur conscience écoutez-le aussi
terrible aussi odieux que soit leurs
actes il les points d'hommes en cette
terre dans la culpabilité soit totale
19h28 l'Assemblée nationale vient
d'abolir la peine de mort
que les grandes idées soient portées par
une grande écriture c'est aussi quelque
chose d'important ça donne du relief à
tout cela l'abolition était votée au
Sénat le 30 septembre
à midi et demi j'ai regardé la pendule
30 septembre à 15 ans ou 16 ans ou 17
ans j'étais tout à fait contre
on considère qu'il y avait des crimes
tellement abominable qu'il ne pouvait
que déboucher sur la peine de mort et
puis bon j'ai évolué comme je vous l'ai
dit dans les années 80 j'aurais
évidemment été avec Jacques Chirac
Jacques Toubon et beaucoup de nos
parlementaires à l'époque en faveur de
cette abolition il y a des sujets qui
transcendent les clivages politiques
c'est vrai que c'était au-delà des
divisions politiques traditionnelles
et ça la force de conviction de Robert
boninter
assister sur le caractère
philosophique profond beaucoup plus que
sur la dimension politique c'était pour
nous ça allait de soi voilà c'était il
fallait le faire il y a des moments où
le calcul politique ou électoral
n'est pas premier il y a des moments
contrairement à ce qu'on croit souvent
où les hommes politiques réagissent par
conviction parce qu'ils ont des
convictions fondamentales et je crois
que sur ce sujet là comme sur celui de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
Chirac sans doute Mitterrand aussi ont
agi par conviction profonde et embêtant
peut-être de côté les sondages
[Musique]
une fois au pouvoir Jacques Chirac
préfère lui mettre l'accent sur des
réformes moins politiques plus
quotidienne qui en tout cas ne déchaîne
pas les patients
[Musique]
Chirac choisit trois dossiers
présidentiels le handicap
tout ce qui concerne la sécurité
automobile et le Plan Cancer
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics qui a été l'objet de discussion
énorme naturellement c'est pas les
grands réformes mais c'est les réformes
qui touchent la vie quotidienne des
Français il faut des réformes sociétales
qui sont des ruptures et des réformes
sociales qui reposent sur un texte
fondateur qui donne des outils mais
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre c'est à la
fois peut-être moins ambitieux mais
beaucoup plus difficile de faire des
réformes sociales que des réformes
sociétales ce ne sont pas des réformes
qui apparaissent comme spectaculaires
mais au fond les accidents sur les
routes se sont effondrées pendant la
période de gouvernement
de Jacques Chirac Jacques Chirac est un
radical socialiste
c'est quelqu'un qui ne croit pas que
l'on fait avancer la société par des
ruptures jamais on avait vu passation
des pouvoirs aussi courtes entre deux
premiers ministres même au temps des
cohabitations mitterrandiriales Jacques
Chirac devra néanmoins accepter une
vraie réforme de société qui n'a pas
souhaité après la dissolution de 1997 il
a perdu sa majorité ni en Alsace pas et
Premier ministre dans le programme de la
gauche pluriel figure le PACS pacte
civil de solidarité si Chirac n'avait
pas dissout l'Assemblée je pense qu'on
aurait pas eu de pacte civil de
solidarité parce que évidemment cette
chose là cette dissolution absurde
erreur politique magistrale prend tout
le monde au dépourvu sa majorité et puis
son opposition je veux parler du droit
du mariage
il ne faut pas prendre le risque de
dénaturer ce droit ni de le banaliser en
mettant sur le même plan d'autres
réalités humaines de notre temps qui
conduisent bien loin des valeurs
fondatrices de la famille une partie de
bras de fer entre le Premier ministre
Lionel Jospin et le président Chirac
peut-être ce que il y avait eu de sa
part
l'idée qu'il fallait peut-être faire
quelques gestes mais aussi il avait dû
beaucoup apprendre de la première
cohabitation avec François Mitterrand et
les opposants sont très nombreux parce
qu'il y a des gens dans leur
circonscription qui disent oui c'est le
mariage il s'est passé le mariage des
homosexuels c'est le mariage des [__]
dans la dans la société très importante
au départ c'était surtout pour régler
les problèmes affreux affronter les
couples homosexuels
nous étions décidés à ne pas en faire
une catégorie
particulière c'est à dire à se référer à
l'universalisme républicain qui veut que
on ne fasse pas de catégories en France
et c'est comme ça que nous avons
descendu ce
ces propositions cette proposition de
loi depuis tout ce matin l'assemblée
nationale est attentive c'est qu'on
discute du PACS le débat est autant
politique que de société le gouvernement
RAL c'est un texte qui ouvre des droits
nouveaux sans en supprimer notre
argumentation c'était de dire mais
attendez ces couples existent bon et
l'homosexualité évidemment n'est
nintendar ou une perversion là longtemps
prétendue ni d'ailleurs une maladie
c'est comme ça c'est une façon pour
certaines personnes te vivre leur
sexualité donc est-ce qu'on va continuer
à les ostraciser et d'ailleurs
est-ce que
le PACS menace quoi que ce soit ça
apporte quelque chose de plus à beaucoup
de gens et ça n'enlève rien à personne
vous voyez or quand quelque chose
apporte un plus à toute une catégorie de
la population et n'en est rien à
personne en général c'est une bonne
réforme
mais nous sommes tous dans la rue pour
danser contre le PACS
[Applaudissements]
il y aura plus rien c'est un problème
politique c'est la gauche sialo
communiste qui veut l'imposer à notre
pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on se souvient de Christine Boutin par
exemple qui brandissait la Bible dans
dans l'assemblée
qui a parlé cinq heures d'affilée
performance qu'il faut saluer l'UDF
Christine Boutin dépasse le temps prévu
de 4 heures elle tient 5h30 pour
défendre sa motion d'y recevabilité je
me souviens de là aussi de d'insultes et
d'injures
ignore
les victimes se lèveront
un député au fond qui avait comparé
l'homosexualité à la zoophilie après de
nouveaux tumulte dans l'après-midi
certains en viennent presquement
politique intérieure avec une véritable
tempête la nuit dernière à l'Assemblée
autour du débat sur le PACS a été
houleuse avec beaucoup d'incidents on
s'attendait à des débats où le à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui et ça
n'a pas manqué il y avait des membres de
l'opposition d'alors qui était quand
même partagée toute cette période du
PACS j'ai refusé toute confrontation
avec Christine Boutin les choses étaient
trop vulgaires de l'autre côté
je voulais me préserver je voulais
préserver mon intégrité
c'est l'honneur d'un parlementaire de
voter selon sa conscience et c'est
l'honneur d'un groupe parlementaire
d'accepter les différences et donc je
vais monter
à la tribu
dans un silence que je n'ai jamais
entendu
[Musique]
Roselyne c'était une conviction pour
elle et elle a eu elle a eu beaucoup de
courage il faut dire que son groupe l'a
laissé prendre la parole aussi j'ai
remanié 20 fois mon texte
et Philippe Seguin me demande de venir
lui dire mon texte dans son bureau de
président du RPR je me souviens comme si
c'était hier du regard très très noir
très puissant de Philippe Seguin il
était en communion avec moi
il va me demander d'ajouter que le RPR
m'a autorisé m'a donné 5 minutes je veux
remercier
Philippe Seguin et Jean-Louis Debré de
m'avoir proposé de m'exprimer en toute
liberté tout le monde se demandait et
dans mes opposants et dans ceux qui me
soutenaient comment j'allais m'en tirer
oui il est utile qui existe dans notre
droit une structure de compagnonnage
impliquant une solidarité globale entre
deux personnes qui ont choisi de vivre
ensemble car finalement nous ne
reconnaissons ici qu'une communauté la
République
je m'assiez à mon banc les gens ont dit
que je pleurais j'ai jamais pleuré
je suis prostré d'émotion j'ai envie de
me cacher de mettre ma tête dans mes
mains et là c'est le souvenir de Simone
Veil qui m'en empêche parce que je
revois
ce geste qu'elle a la photo où elle est
au bon des ministres et pour arriver à
surmonter l'émotion et la fatigue qui
l'a submerge elle met sa tête dans les
mains et je me dis je ne peux pas lui
voler son geste je n'ai pas le droit de
lui voler donc je descends et c'est le
souvenir de Simone qui m'habite
dans les gouvernements auxquels j'ai
appartenu
les femmes ont toujours été solidaires
entre elles
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un hasard si les différents
présidents de la Cinquième République
depuis Giscard on confiait la plupart
des grandes batailles de sociétés à des
femmes
ces grands débats de société sont très
intéressants
mais ils sont me semble-t-il à mettre en
parallèle
avec la façon dont les présidents
vivaient leur vie aussi
je veux dire que
il y avait une grande modernité chez
chaque président qui a fait des réformes
de société pour les autres
mais pas tellement pour eux
François Mitterrand Jacques Chirac était
bien d'accord là-dessus pour faire
carrière fallait pas divorcé
comme si le divorce ou l'absence de
divorce est un élément de la carrière
politique
la famille recomposée du président de la
République est arrivé au grand complet
une famille moderne qui fait face aux
objectifs
full le tapis rouge
gravit les marches
un genre inédit dans la cour de l'Élysée
était une femme
mais il n'est pas question pour moi
d'aller au marché et d'avoir un panier
avec huit femmes et un panier avec 8
hommes ça n'a aucun sens je voulais la
parité mais la vraie moi je ne suis pas
fier du calcul numérique autant de
femmes que d'hommes c'est si facile
et ça même un côté un peu humiliant pour
dire les choses là où je suis fier
c'est quelle femme
parce que si vous regardez Christine
Lagarde Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
Valérie Pécresse Michel Alliot-Marie
des postes très importants mais je n'ai
pas voulu que ça j'ai aussi voulu de la
diversité la jeune RAMAYADE une femme
garde des sceaux avec un père algérien
et une mère marocaine mais c'est très
important
sans identité il n'y a pas de diversité
enfin moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'un
président de la République ne devait pas
être
Hibernatus
au sens du film de Louis de Funès c'est
à dire
sans sentiment et sans vie
moi
j'ai divorcé pendant mon quinquennat et
je me suis marié
j'ai dit
un président c'est un être humain
et c'est important de rester un être
humain on me l'a reprochait
mais est-ce que c'est pas ça la
modernité au fond comprenez-moi j'ai pas
divorcé j'ai subi mon divorce j'ai pas
divorcé pour être quelqu'un de moderne
et je me suis pas marié avec Carla pour
écrire qu'un moderne je me suis marié
avec Carla parce que je l'aimais et on a
divorcé parce que Cécile à l'époque
voulait divorcé mais est-ce que c'est
pas ça la modernité c'est à dire de
s'appliquer à soi-même
les règles que Monsieur Dupont Madame
Durand
s'applique de leur vie quotidienne
mais vous vouliez vous voulez dire que
vous avez fait en vous-même en quelque
sorte une réforme de société non je
voulais dire que la réforme de société
c'est que le président dise la vérité de
sa vie
ne mentent pas sur sa vie
et que peut-être que ça c'est pas un
texte de loi mais peut-être que ça fait
évoluer les choses beaucoup plus que
tout un tas de textes de lois
[Musique]
ça m'a beaucoup servi pendant une
campagne présidentielle et ça sans doute
desservi dès que je suis devenu
président
parce que le mot n'était plus compris
puisque forcément c'est une fonction
exceptionnelle mais pour exercer cette
fonction exceptionnelle il faut rester
soi-même c'est ça que je voulais
signifier il faut être capable de
maîtriser parfois son caractère et aussi
d'être simple d'être soucieux de de se
mettre au niveau du citoyen moi
président de la République j'essaierai
d'avoir de la hauteur de jus pour fixer
les grandes orientations les grandes
impulsions mais en même temps je ne
m'occuperai pas de tout et j'aurai
toujours le souci de la proximité
certains au moment de la campagne
électorale de 2012 me disait mais quel
est votre grande réforme de société pour
Giscard d'estains donc l'IVG pour
François Mitterrand l'abolition de la
peine de mort mais pour vous quel est
votre grande réforme de société et
j'étais devant la rédaction de
Libération comme candidat
et je dis vous savez la grande réforme
de société ça va être le mariage pour
tous j'ai pris un engagement d'ailleurs
c'est celui du Parti socialiste et il
faudra le tenir lorsque nous serons
responsabilités de la France c'est le
droit aux mariages pour tous les couples
et je sentais bien un peu de sourire ou
de sarcasme qui sort quand même c'est
tellement facile de voter cette réforme
tout le monde est d'accord les sondages
vont dans le même sens mais je dis mais
vous ne savez pas ce qu'est la société
française comment elle va réagir quels
sont les groupes qu'il a à travailler
quels sont les parties de l'opinion qui
sont très mobilisés comment elles vont
s'organiser
donc vient d'être élu et
certains me disent mettons le mariage
pour tous tout de suite à l'ordre du
jour de de l'Assemblée nationale au mois
d'octobre et j'ai considéré qu'il y
avait d'autres textes et que je n'avais
pas été lu que sur cette réforme et
qu'il y avait des mesures économiques
sociales le chômage était en train de de
progresser dangereusement l'industrie
était en très grande difficulté qu'il
fallait d'abord faire que l'automne
servent aux mesures économiques et nous
ferions la réforme sur le mariage pour
tous à partir du mois de janvier
monsieur le Président Mesdames sur les
députés monsieur le député le mariage
pour tous était un sujet quand même très
difficile pour les français c'était un
sujet qui était naturellement
globalement majoritairement partagé mais
qui heurte beaucoup de gens au fond ce
qui était ce que souhaitait les les
homosexuels c'est se voir reconnu de
façon beaucoup plus symbolique comme
comme étant normaux comme les autres il
y a des
familles humour dans des couples hétéros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans exception derrière c'était quand
même c'est une révolution dans le droit
de la famille c'est un contestable
le mariage pour tous divise la France
derrière leur égérie frigides barjot les
opposants à la loi multiplient les
manifestations donc ce qui s'est produit
ne ma pas surpris c'est à dire que il y
a eu de manifestations importantes avec
des excès tout à fait déplorables mais
le débat c'est prolongé et c'est ce
qu'il y a effectivement entraîné une
mobilisation plus forte à mesure que le
temps passé des défilés
fois dans la violence quand l'extrême
droite joint au Cort
ège vous avez jamais envisagé vous êtes
jamais dit là est-ce que est-ce que je
peux continuer
mais puisque j'ai reçu des manifestants
vas-y mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
un autre nom que le mariage
que ça s'appelle palmariage et pourquoi
ça ne s'appellerait pas le mariage
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'il n'y ait
pas d'adoption alors que
principe même du mariage c'est de
pouvoir aller jusqu'à l'adoption
d'enfant
donc voilà pourquoi j'ai considère qu'il
y avait finalement c'était le retrait
total ou le maintien total il n'y avait
pas de demi mariage
coup de force la parole est à Madame
Christiane Taubira garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés merci
elle a vraiment porté au Parlement cette
question avec beaucoup de générosité
beaucoup de liberté et elle a fait un
discours d'ouverture absolument
magistral c'est à dire qu'elle a vanté
les mérites du mariage
en général
vous avez donc que les mots de père et
maire ne disparaissent pas du Code civil
ils sont maintenus en l'état c'est à peu
près contre-pied tous ceux qui
prétendaient que le mariage pour tous
allait saper cette institution
fondamentale du droit de la famille sur
la forme on est gêné on est surpris on a
été dans les situations inattendues mais
au fond quand on aime on aime et on aime
quel que soit les circonstances
nous les chiens nous les rien nous les
maigres nous les [__]
qu'attendons-nous
qu'attendons-nous pour faire les fous
pisser un coup sur cette vie stupide et
bête qui nous est faite si nous si nous
nous n'accordons pas l'égalité des
droits si nous nous reconnaissons pas la
liberté nous leur disons
qu'attendez-vous pour faire les fous sur
cette vie stupide qui vous est faite
et voilà monsieur Mariton vous avez
permis la rencontre de la justice et de
la poésie le fait qu'elle est qu'elle
est parsemelle débat de référence et de
citation littéraires
et poétique je crois que ça ça non je
crois que ça a aidé le débat je pense
que pour les réformes de société il faut
qu'il y ait du débat mais que le débat
ne doit pas être trop long car quand il
s'installe il se cristallise il se
durcit et un moment j'ai été amené comme
président de la République à dire bon
voilà tant du débat par le moteur a été
long chacun a pu s'exprimer il faut en
finir il faut voter après 136 heures et
46 minutes de débat
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi ouvrant le mariage au couple de
personnes de même sexe
on a vu vraiment
s'exprimer non pas
ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal mais
ce qui est d'avenir et ce qui est du
passé les mariages ce sont déroulés sur
un incident grave des mers ont refuse on
refuse de reconnaître mais ensuite c'est
passé dans les mœurs voilà et quelle est
la plus grande satisfaction quand il y a
une réforme de société
a pu connaître des oppositions fortes
j'ai parlé de l'IVG ou du mariage pour
tous ou de l'abolition de la peine de
mort c'est qu'ensuite finalement c'est
cette réforme s'installe et plus
personne ne la remet en cause en France
on se bat mais de façon totale
jusqu'à la minute ou la réforme est
votée elle est votée plus personne n'en
parle
seul c'est fini à part deux ou trois
exaltés plus personne
ça a été violent
et ruptif explosif c'est voter terminé
et le droit est là pour
consacrer ces évolutions de la société
heureusement que le droit de la famille
et le droit des femmes ne sont pas ce
qu'ils étaient au 19e siècle et
aujourd'hui dans la société française
tout le monde tout le monde sans
exception
fusse les familles les plus
traditionnelles a vu autour de lui
quelle révolution portait des choix de
vie
qu'elle et c'est des révolutions qu'on
ne peut pas ignorer et j'ai une anecdote
qui me revient parce qu'il y avait un
maire qui qui protestait et qui ne
ferait jamais de mariage jusqu'au jour
où son fils lui a annoncé qui allait se
marier avec un compagnon
[Musique]
la PMA étendue à toutes les femmes
qu'elle soit célibataires ou en couple
avec une autre femme sujet
ultra-sensible plusieurs fois reporté
sur ces sujets de société
le politique ne doit pas imposer un
choix en brutalisant les consciences
évidemment la grande crainte et bien
c'est de revivre le mariage pour tous
ce qui manifestaient pour le mariage
pour tous ne se sont plus senti portés
par une
par un élan général
le débat qui a été enclenché avec la
réforme du mariage pour tous a été un
débat qui a dominé tous les autres et
donc ça en effet étouffé les types de
contestation et tant mieux si ça a été
dans un relatif calme que ce texte a pu
être voté sous la présence d'Emmanuel
Macron
la société est toujours comme ça la
société
aspire à l'immédiat et puis elle est en
même temps des aspirations de profondeur
et donc c'est ça la politique assez de
veiller à ce que
l'opinion publique de s'enflamme pas à
un moment sur un sujet sur un autre le
sens du timing est très important des
des bonnes réformes proposées à des
moments inopportuns donne des flops il y
a effectivement un dilemme est-ce qu'il
faut laisser le temps pour que la
société elle-même intègre l'idée de
cette réforme ou est-ce que au contraire
il faut passer rapidement pour que les
crispations ne se cristallisent pas et
que ça ne devienne pas un empêchement
après tout est-ce que c'est pas ça la
démocratie est-ce que c'est pas ça un
moment donné le fait que le dernier mot
reste au peuple même si la manifestation
dans la rue n'est pas forcément la
meilleure solution mais après tout
aujourd'hui je suis juge constitutionnel
la liberté de manifester la liberté de
grève sont des droits constitutionnels
fondamentaux
[Musique]